it's amazing what you can do when you're
just authentic it's amazing what you can
do when you just true to yourself I am a
woman with a beard when a beard is
supposed to be a manly thing my name's
her NomCom 26 years old I work as an
anti-bullying activist and I model to
polycystic ovary syndrome is as simple
as saying that I have more testosterone
in my body than the female sex hormone
and the side effect of the condition is
weight gain or weight loss diabetes
alopecia obviously facial hair in school
I was bullied horrendously because of
the way that my body was I thought that
the building would stop if I removed my
facial hair so I started tweezing
bleaching waxing shaving using hair
removal creams but the hair growth just
came back even longer darker thicker I
was at the age of 16 and I hit my lowest
I was very suicidal and I was just sick
and tired of all the body shaming and
bullying and people not letting me live
my life say what I want to I felt right
you're gonna grow your beard out and see
how you like her and see how she forms
in your face
[Music]
I obviously look after my bed I've given
her name is old sundar Lee I think a lot
of men just look at me because my beards
is sometimes a lot better than theirs
sorry all the negativity that I went
through I turned into something positive
and I made a career out of it you know
I'm in the media actually everywhere
very fortunate to you know to be able to
reach such vast amount of people because
there are so many women out there even
men that suffer from body shaming but
don't speak about it one woman said I'm
not suicidal because of you so that to
me just really ensured to me that yeah
you know what you're doing is positive
in having a positive effect on people if
there was a pill that could reverse all
this no would never take it I can't say
I love this but I don't love that no
100% love myself
you
you